retour en france nicolas sarkozy assure
le service après-vente de la réforme de
l'hôpital nouvelle version il était un
an si aujourd'hui les manifestants
étaient tenus à distance
mais le chef de l'état a été interpellé
par les personnels tirer curtet alain
duban 400 mètres tout autour du chu de
nancy transformer en glacis un policier
tous les 5 mètres
les véhicules stationnés enlever les
centres des villes accueillant le
président de la république sont
désormais quadrillé et les manifestants
un millier ce matin relégué loin des
cortèges les officiants quand un gars
devront tous les moyens qui sont qui
sont mis en oeuvre
pourquoi pourquoi parce que monsieur
vient ils entendaient protester contre
les 660 suppressions d'emplois l'hôpital
de la ville
nicolas sarkozy tente d'apaiser les
esprits
si tout allait bien je serai pas là
mais la santé et brad et non moi j'évite
de facteurs d'évolution
mais il est surtout venu expliquer les
concessions faites aux médecins pour les
réintroduire dans la gestion des
hôpitaux et il a averti
je crois qu'on a trouvé un bon équilibre
nous n'irons pas plus loin mais tout le
monde n'est pas convaincu
l'appel à la grève nationale dans les
hôpitaux et maintenus pour gérer la
situation